le Val de Loire terre de Bonvin on vient
de le voir de magnifiques châteaux mais
également d'inventeur rencontre à
présent avec Jean-yves boulet cet
habitant de sachet a conçu un
purificateur d'air personnel une
invention primée au dernier concours
Lépine et que nous présente Clémence
dosc
100% made in Touraine la coiffe portée
par Jean-Yves Boulay est un purificateur
d'air légèrement modifié pour éviter les
projections de peinture il lui permet de
ne pas respirer les vapeurs du produit
imaginez pendant la pandémie le WHY Cut
est à l'image de son inventeur une
alliance entre l'art et la technique
c'est le produit d'une expérience
utilisateur voilà moi je suis à la base
à la base je suis carrossier peinte j'ai
travaillé dans l'industrie dans plein de
secteurs différents chimie pétrochimie
format agro j'ai fait aussi même de
l'automobile et j'ai travaillé 11 ans
dans nucléaire j'ai fait aussi l'armée
pendant la covid j'étais au chantier
naval de Saint-Nazaire donc tous les
problèmes de protection des voies
respiratoires en fait tous les
dispositifs qui existent quasiment sur
le marché je les ai utilisés
protéger des allergies des maladies ou
encore de la pollution les réponses
techniques apportées par cette bulle
d'air sont nombreuses à l'intérieur de
la coiffe un jeu de filtre charbon et
d'aspiration puis une lumière UVC pour
éliminer les germes le fonctionne avec
une batterie rechargeable donc là je
suis protégé et le dispositif tel qu'il
est configuré actuellement on est 400 à
500 fois plus efficace qu'un masque
chirurgical une innovation récompensée
par une médaille d'or au concours Les
Pins mais l'aventure est loin d'être
terminée prochaine étape pour le tour en
Jau et ses deux associés convaincre des
investisseurs et industrialisés sont
produits